I said I feel better than I probably
should since I had this seven and a half
pound baby with no anesthesia it
happened so fast and the real story oh
yeah I was like oh my God so anyway she
says well if it wouldn't be too much
trouble if you can come outside and do
the rest of the show we have you back in
before you know you're gone I'm like
what you want me to come outside to the
sidewalk and do a television show I said
Sheila they haven't let me walk to the
bathroom yet I'm pretty sure the
sidewalk is out of range and do you
remember those outfits they give you
here I mean like everything's showing in
the back it's not happening and then she
said we're desperate we have to have you
I was like okay if it's okay with the
hospital and it doesn't disturb any
other ladies on the maternity floor I'll
do it on one condition hair and makeup
come an hour before the crew so my
picture that picture you saw I had
professional hair professional makeup I
had somebody bring me something decent
that I could wear you know as a shirt
and this is the way the hospitals can
make money if they have a staff makeup
person in the Maternity Ward think about
it